long before Russian tanks rolled into
Ukraine a year ago Russia had started a
campaign of what we now know as
disinformation the disinformation that
uh that Russia is promoting amplifying
on social media and on their state media
platforms is um is directly intended to
erode Western and Canadian public
support for Ukraine last October the
Trudeau cabinet wanted to know how
disinformation was affecting the ability
of Canadians to tell fact from fiction
through an access to information request
Global News has learned that as part of
the weekly internal polling program
overseen by the pmo Canadians were asked
what impact do you think disinformation
is having on Canadians ability to tell
the difference between true and false
information about the conflict 37
percent said it is having a major impact
35 percent said it was having a minor
impact while just 17 percent said no
impact I hope that the government looks
at these numbers and has an uh can can
clearly see that this is uh this is a
significant problem and that even
Canadians regular Canadians are
recognizing it as such
opposition MP say the Trudeau government
needs to act on the data it collected
there's disinformation campaign is
undermining our own democracy and this
disinformation campaign is hurting
Western support in prime minister Justin
Trudeau said Friday his government would
do more we we will continue to support
Brave journalists who are telling the
truth
who are sharing actual news and facts
around the world
we will continue to ensure
that there is no place for the lies that
Putin is sharing
for now though the most visible part of
Canada's campaign to counter
disinformation consists of this
two-month-old government website that
fact checks false Russian claims David
Akin Global News
Ottawa